wenig gemeinsamkeit unterschiedliche
wege der streit zwischen den ländern um
die krone lockerungen verschärft sich
frankreichs autoindustrie kämpft mit den
corona folgen präsident marco legt einen
8 milliarden euro rettungsplan vor und
urlaub im corona sommer die
bundesregierung will die weltweite
reisewarnung offenbar teilweise aufheben
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg dienstag der 26 guten
abend schön dass sie dabei sind
einheitlich und abgestimmt so wollten
bund und länder die korona krise
eigentlich mal meistern
doch dieser vorsatz ist längst
geschichte mittlerweile lockert jedes
land die beschränkungen wie es das für
richtig hält auch heute wieder
weitere konferenzen zwischen
ministerpräsidenten und kanzlerin seien
gerade nicht sinnvoll heißt es
inzwischen aus stuttgart münchen und
berlin
bundesweit gilt nur noch das
abstandhalten wo es geht wer einkauft
oder im nahverkehr unterwegs ist muss
einen mund nasen schutz tragen und
großveranstaltungen wie volksfeste und
festivals bleiben erst einmal verboten
abgesehen davon geht jedes land seinen
eigenen weg und dabei wird deutlich je
mehr lockerung desto lauter die kritik
melanie hat berichtet markus söder will
nur leicht lockern
ab mitte juli werden in bayern theater
und kinos öffnen dürfen unter auflagen
föderales handeln ja sagt er heute
aber beim infektionsschutz nicht ohne
generelle führung vom bund über die
gesamtentwicklung bin ich ein bisschen
unglücklich in den letzten wochen
unglücklich deswegen weil es immer mehr
zu einem auseinanderbrechen in der
inderin in der frage geht was das
fundament herausforderung im moment ist
mein eindruck dass das gesamte fundament
und die akzeptanz für gemeinschaftliche
lösung zählt zurückgeht
nachdem einige länder immer wieder
vorpreschen sieht söder nun wenig sinn
in weiteren gemeinsamen runden mit der
kanzlerin
eine entwicklung die immer mehr fahrt
aufnimmt heute haben wieder mehrere
bundesländer ihre landesweiten vorgaben
gelockert und jedes für sich eigene
entscheidungen getroffen
es liegt in der verantwortung der einst
ministerpräsidenten unter land und
stadtkreise
dies verantwortungsvoll zu anfang auch
in thüringen tagte heute das kabinett
nach dem bodo ramelow am wochenende
vorpreschte und seine idee vom ausstieg
aus dem krisenmodus verkündete war heute
aussprache die entscheidung über seinen
strategiewechsel wurde erst einmal
vertagt ramelow wirbt weiter für seinen
weg dahin
deswegen wollen wir nicht immer weitere
verordnungen machen sondern wollen die
menschen einladen über den sinn und den
sinngehalt der verordnung dahingehend
nachzudenken dass die infektion am
besten geschützt wird wenn man sich
persönlich schützt so ist der vorstoß
von bodo ramelow ein neuer höhepunkt im
streit um zuständigkeiten und
lockerungen der korona maßnahmen und
soeben erreicht uns noch eine einbildung
die kontakt beschränkungen in
deutschland werden bis zum 29
juni verlängert bund und länder einigten
sich darauf dass die länder den
aufenthalt im öffentlichen raum nunmehr
mit bis zu zehn personen oder den
angehörigen zweier haus ständig
gestalten können
das erfuhr die nachrichtenagentur
reuters auch baden-württemberg hat
weitere lockerungen der chor ohne
beschränkungen beschlossen eine davon
wird viele eltern erleichtern
spätestens ende juni sollen alle kinder
wieder in die kita gehen können
zurzeit dürfen die kindergärten und
krippen dort nur halb so viele kinder
betreuen wie sonst nach frankreich die
wirtschaft ächzt auch hier unter den
folgen der korona pandemie jetzt kündigt
präsident makro massive hilfen an
für die autobauer eine der
schlüsselindustrien der ehrgeizige plan
frankreich soll mit milliarden vom staat
europas führender hersteller für
elektroautos werden aus paris christel
hass
hinter den hightech maschinen als
zulieferbetrieb lässt sich der präsident
weiter bilden in sach und autoteile das
thema fahrzeugindustrie brennt allen in
frankreich unter den nägeln die branche
ist in der korona krise schwer ins
straucheln gekommen jetzt soll ihr mit
acht milliarden euro wieder auf die
beine geholfen werden es geht um die
verteidigung unserer industrie
arbeitsplätze die von einer der
schwersten krisen unserer geschichte
betroffen sind
es geht darum dass frankreichs
autobranche souverän wird und so soll
das konkret aussehen
wer ein elektroauto kauft erhält eine
prämie von bis zu 7000 euro
zusätzlich gibt es eine abwrackprämie
für verbrenner die je nach typ 5000 euro
betragen kann
bis 2021 sollen 100.000 ladestationen
aktiv sein
der präsident stellt forderungen an die
autobranche im land produzieren und in
die elektromobilität investieren
vor allem der autobauer renault kämpft
ums überleben
obwohl er sehr früh auf elektroautos
gesetzt hatte es drohen entlassungen
heute also der rettungsplan der der
gesamten wirtschaft wieder schub bringen
soll wenn in anderen ländern es prämien
gibt dann wird die deutsche regierung
hier sicherlich weiter unter druck
kommen weil nun gerade auch in
deutschland die automobilindustrie ein
ganz zentraler baustein der wirtschaft
und auch der beschäftigung
frankreich hat vorgelegt deutschland
überlegt noch ob es folgen will
bundesregierung und lufthansa sind sich
einig der staat greift der airline mit
einem gewaltigen rettungspaket unter die
arme allerdings fehlt noch das okay der
eu kommission und die stellt offenbar
bedingungen
es steht im raum dass die eu
wettbewerbshüter verlangen könnten
dass die lufthansa wichtige start und
landerechte an den hauptstandorten
frankfurt und münchen abgibt was für
unmut sorgt aus der union heißt es die
lufthansa rettung dürfen nicht an den
auflagen der eu kommission scheitern
stefan leifert in brüssel warum will
sich die eu kommission offenbar
ausgerechnet bei der lufthansa
querstellen im moment finanzieren doch
in ganz europa starten ihre fluglinien
ja das stimmt die eu-kommission winkt im
moment staatliche beihilfen quasi im
halb tagesrhythmus durch und dennoch ist
der fall lufthansa aus zwei gründen ein
besonderer zum einen wäre es das erste
mal dass ein start bei einer airline
direct einsteigt und das knüpft die
kommission aus angst vor
wettbewerbsverzerrungen an härtere
auflagen als wenn ein staat einfach
kredite oder staatliche garantien
gewährt und zu solchen auflagen könnte
dann auch der entzug von start und
landerechten gehören der zweite grund
ist etwas grundsätzlicher die in brüssel
geht die angst vor einer deutschen
übermacht bei den antiken bei den corona
hilfsmaßnahmen um von den zwei billionen
die eu-staaten eu weit verteilt haben an
hilfsmaßnahmen fällt allein schon die
hälfte auf deutschland und es gibt hier
zur sorge anlass dass die ökonomischen
ungleichheiten von vor der krise durch
die krisenmaßnahmen nur noch stärker
werden dennoch der fall lufthansa wird
hier wahrscheinlich durchgewunken werden
das ist eine sache von tagen im moment
jedenfalls geht es eher um die frage des
wie und nicht so sehr um die frage des
ob dankeschön für diese einschätzung
nach brüssel stefan leifert war das
ungünstige zeiten sind das für viele
junge leute die im sommer mit der schule
fertig werden und eigentlich eine lehre
machen wollen
in deutschland gibt es rund 400.000
ausbildungsbetriebe ein viertel davon
überlegt ob sie künftig weiter ausbilden
das ergab eine umfrage des
zentralverbands des deutschen handwerks
damit zumindest die aktuellen lehrlinge
weiter machen können haben politik und
wirtschaft einen gemeinsamen plan
entwickelt svend lass es läuft nur
langsam wieder an im hotel und
restaurant von heike gärung kauderer
sechs neue azubi stellt sie
normalerweise pro jahr ein
doch im moment weiß sie nicht wie vielen
jungen menschen sie diesen herbst einen
ausbildungsplatz bieten kann bereits
unterschriebenen verträge wird man
natürlich nehmen
bei den zusätzlichen
wie nicht tatsächlich auch noch nicht
sicher was wir machen
bisher ist die unterstützung im thema
ausbildung noch sehr mäßig gewesen
auch das aufrechterhalten der ausbildung
im moment stellt betriebe vor große
herausforderungen
bei 1 ventilatoren hersteller ebm-papst
sind die azubis derzeit nur jede zweite
woche im betrieb die andere zeit
bekommen die aufgaben für zu hause
immerhin ihre ausbildung ist nicht in
gefahr ich habe von mitschülern oder
freunden die ihm auch in der ausbildung
sind gehört dass es bei ihnen
tatsächlich schwieriger aussieht sogar
schon relativ richtung existenz problem
geht der bundesarbeitsminister
verspricht den namen der allianz für aus
und weiterbildung jetzt unterstützung
die gemeinsame botschaft von politik
arbeitgebern und gewerkschaften
die korona krise darf nicht zu einer
krise auf dem ausbildungsmarkt führen
wir wollen dass möglichst alle jungen
menschen ihre ausbildung erfolgreich
abschließen können wenn sie in
ausbildung sind bzw
für den neuen ausbildungsjahrgang eine
ausbildung beginnen können
so sollen azubis zur not beispielsweise
ihre ausbildung vorübergehend in einem
anderen betrieb fortsetzen oder auch
beginnen können
und wenn ein unternehmen einen azubi aus
einem insolventen betrieb übernimmt
bekommt es dafür eine prämie
es soll außerdem mehr digitale
berufsberatung und digitales lernen
ermöglicht werden
vieles erst mal absichtserklärungen
jetzt geht es um die konkrete umsetzung
viele betriebe und azubis hoffen dass
das schnell geht der blick auf die
aktuellen zahlen in deutschland zeigt
die neuinfektionen bewegen sich weiter
auf einem niedrigen niveau
im durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben
tage steckten sich 580 menschen pro tag
mit dem corona virus an
insgesamt sind rund 180.000 800 fälle
durch tests bestätigt mehr als 1000 160
1800 erkrankte gelten als genesen 8347
menschen starben in zusammenhang mit
cupid 19
als erstes großunternehmen in
deutschland will die post tausenden
ihrer mitarbeiter vorbeugende corona
tests anbieten
vor allem in pakete und briefe verteilt
zentren erste untersuchungen haben
nämlich gezeigt dass es dort viele
infizierte gab die keinerlei symptome
hatten david sauer details die sorge war
groß bei der nachtschicht des
briefverteilzentrum es bei potsdam
bei sieben mitarbeitern wurde das corona
virus nachgewiesen haben sie etwa andere
angesteckt alle rund 100 kollegen wurden
gestern und heute von betriebsärzten
getestet ergebnisse stehen noch aus
[Applaus]
der post-konzern wir jetzt klarheit über
die situation und bietet zehntausenden
mitarbeitern bundesweit tests an den
sortierzentren haben sie halt
arbeitsvorgänge wo kollegen sehr dicht
auch miteinander arbeiten müssten wären
deshalb uns dazu entschlossen nach einer
gewissen kriterienliste eine reihe von
diesen in den nächsten wochen so zu
testen das alle mitarbeiter auf corona
getestet werden
zuerst sollen mitarbeiter getestet
werden wenn es im betrieb infektionen
gibt der landkreis viele infektionen
meldet oder wenn die lebensumstände eine
infektion wahrscheinlicher machen durch
alter oder wohnsituation etwa
arbeitnehmervertreter begrüßen den post
vorstoß im wesentlichen also erst mal
ist das von der post ehrenwert dass sie
sich einen überblick über das
infektionsgeschehen verschaffen wollen
das kann man machen wenn es freiwillig
ist also wenn die tester das freiwillig
vornehmen lassen und ihnen kein nachteil
daraus erwächst wenn sie es nicht testen
lassen
es ersetzt aber keinesfalls die
arbeitsschutzmaßnahmen weiter wichtig
händewaschen abstand halten
um neue groß ausbrüche zu verhindern
einen standort im kreis heinsberg hatte
der post konkurrent dpd vor zehn tagen
schließen müssen
bei etwa 80 von 400 mitarbeitern war das
virus nachgewiesen worden
wichtige entscheidungen des
bundesverfassungsgerichts es geht um die
rentenansprüche nach einer scheidung
genauer gesagt um die art wie
betriebsrenten zwischen den eheleuten
aufgeteilt werden die bisher ihre
bisherige regelung ist
verfassungsgemäß sagen die richter aber
die familiengerichte müssen künftig
darauf achten dass vor allem frauen bei
der berechnung ihrer ansprüche nicht
systematisch benachteiligt werden 70
täter 44 opfer plus unmengen von dateien
voller kinderpornografie noch wird im
fall bergisch gladbach ermittelt er ist
bereits jetzt eine der größten
missbrauchsfälle in deutschland
die männer sollen kleinkinder
missbraucht und bilder davon in ihrem
netzwerk ausgetauscht haben
der erste von ihnen wurde jetzt schuldig
gesprochen und in die geschlossene
psychiatrie eingewiesen dauert der
färber er missbrauchte seine tochter auf
dem wickeltisch sie war gerade erst ein
paar monate alt sein stiefsohn war vier
jahre alt die nichte 3 die tochter eines
chat partners zwei jahre alt fotos und
videos erteilte der soldat im netz nun
das urteil zehn jahre haft anschließend
geschlossene psychiatrie
zugunsten des angeklagten dass er sich
hier weitestgehend geständig eingelassen
hat zu seinen lasten jedoch dass die
taten über einen längeren zeitraum
erfolgt sind und insbesondere auch
gegenüber sehr jungen kindern
stattgefunden haben dass die kinder auch
heute noch sexualisiertes verhalten
zeigen dass überhaupt nicht kindgerecht
ist beispielsweise die nachfrage nach
nach welchem sexspielzeugen kinder die
missbraucht als normalität empfinden es
ist das erste urteil im
ermittlungskomplex der in bergisch
gladbach begann ein bundesweiter
tauschring von kinderpornografie bei dem
die täter auch gemeinsam kinder
missbrauchten
einige stehen jetzt vor gericht in
anderen fällen wird noch ermittelt
wir haben über 70 meter bis jetzt wir
haben 44 die opfer und es waren 300 über
300 mitarbeiter der polizei und jetzt
rund 120 jetzt noch arbeiten also es ist
schon eine riesige dimension ich bin
sicher das ist noch lange nicht zu ende
die menge an fotos und videos mit
missbrauchsdarstellungen ist so groß
dass noch immer nicht alles an
bewertet ist dazu müssen chat gruppen
mit hunderten teilnehmern nachverfolgt
werden
das urteil heute ist nur ein anfang
zurück zu corona und den auswirkungen
auf die wirtschaft viele länder die vom
tourismus abhängen haben jetzt massiv
probleme zb die türkei hier hatte die
reisebranche 2009 10 noch mehr als 32
milliarden euro eingenommen geschätzt
zwei drittel davon werden in diesem jahr
wegfallen
dabei wäre das geld der touristen so
wichtig für das land um seine tiefe
wirtschaftskrise zu überwinden ja blase
berichtet gewinner der korona krise gibt
es in der türkei nur wenige der
wohnwagen bauerbach hulu gehört dazu
viele türken aber auch kunden auf der
ganzen welt entdecken den urlaub auf
rädern die auftragsbücher sind voll
es hat bewegung gegeben ich sowohl auf
dem inlands als auch auf dem
auslandsmarkt zum beispiel haben wir
letzte woche wohnwagen nach norwegen
geliefert und heute ist noch eine
bestellung aus norwegen im internet
reingekommen anderen unternehmen dem
tourismusgeschäft aber geht es lange
nicht so gut im gegenteil die türkische
regierung versucht die hotel so bald wie
möglich wieder zu öffnen auch für
ausländische gäste
dafür wurden bereits gespräche mit
deutschland und den anderen europäern
geführt auch wenn es noch keine
regulären linienflüge geben wird wollen
wir charter- reisen anbieten die
touristen sollen von der an bis zur
rückreise betreut werden so dass sie
ihre ferien in der türkei sehr sicher
verbringen können
die türkische wirtschaft steht unter
druck der kurs der währung sagte ab
arbeitslosigkeit und inflation steigen
die staatlichen rücklagen schwind im
jahr 2020 wird die türkische wirtschaft
schrumpfen um rund fünf prozent schätzt
der internationale währungsfonds aber
ich denke das ist so optimistisch ich
rechne eher mit bis zu zehn prozent
die türkische regierung muss die
wirtschaft also wieder ankurbeln und der
tourismus auch aus deutschland spielt
dabei eine wichtige rolle
vier wochen nur noch bis zum beginn der
sommerferien in den ersten bundesländern
da kommt diese nachricht vielen sicher
gelegen die bundesregierung bereitet
offenbar ein ende ihrer weltweiten
reisewarnung vor
ab dem 15 juni für 31 europäische
staaten
so steht es laut dpa in einem entwurf
für das kabinett aus berlin romanesco
war
die vorbereitungen laufen anders aber
als in den vorjahren abstand halten
oberstes gebot auch in den
urlaubsregionen die weltweite
reisewarnung soll durch reisehinweise
für das jeweilige land ersetzt werden
trotzdem beim thema ferien im ausland
bleiben viele skeptisch selbst wenn man
ins reisen würde werden da viel zu viele
einschränkungen vor ort keiner lust
irgendwie darüber zu fahren vielleicht
irgendwo im kanton zu sitzen
man kann noch in deutschland stehen das
schöne sachen machen
von einer steigenden reiselust spürt
auch jörg wärme wenig das ende der
reisewarnung könnte den reisebüros zwar
helfen so viel sei aber immer noch
unklar
kämen jetzt die kunden eine empfehlung
wäre schwierig wenn wir die glaskugel
hätten um zu sagen wie genau die
situation ist was geht was nicht geht
dann werden wir alle ein ganz ganz
großen schritt weiter auf jeden fall
wird die pauschalreise anders das zeigen
die jüngst veröffentlichten regeln des
branchenverbandes so soll beispielsweise
die bewirtung nur in zeitlich geordneten
gruppen erfolgen auf buffets nach
möglichkeit ganz verzichtet werden ein
mindestabstand auch für pool und strand
bestuhlung gelten die deutsche luftfahrt
setzt zudem bei flügen auf masken
pflicht und besonders saubere luft
wir haben an bord unserer flugzeuge die
situation dass für die kabinenluft
permanent reinigen mit hochleistungs
filtern dh eventuell viren und bakterien
werden dort herausgefiltert sommerurlaub
2020 für manche wohl zu viele
einschränkungen für andere aber
vielleicht die große chance auf ferien
ganz ohne drängelei eher spröder
berliner wird zwar ihr kapital solo
sunny ihre erfolgreichste rolle
die schauspielerin renate costner ist
mit 75 jahren gestorben
kressner spielt zunächst am theater in
den 70ern wird sie zum star des ddr
films für solo sunny bekommt sie 1980
den berliner bären 1997 den grimme preis
für diesel
nach der wende ist sie vor allem im
fernsehen zu sehen zum beispiel an der
seite von zdf kommissar stubbe
die kunst ist das beste aus den corona
abstandsregeln zu machen wie das gehen
kann demonstriert ein gastwirt im
hessischen hofheim große knuddelige
teddybären stellen sicher dass sich die
gäste in seinem restaurant dich zu nahe
kommen und bringen die leute zudem noch
zum schmunzeln sagt der chef das wetter
ist eigentlich auch zum lächeln meist
trocken und angenehm warum die
langfassung kommt gleich von katja uni
viertel vor zehn freut sich claus kleber
im heute journal auf sie und wir freuen
uns wenn sie morgen
wieder dabei sein möchten ich wünsche
ihnen noch einen schönen abend auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren es gibt ein
deutliches ost west gefälle was die
wolken angeht hier über polen waren die
wolken heute etwas dichter über
frankreich sagen wer dagegen kaum eine
wolke und hier in deutschland waren
einige wolken unterwegs sind auch jetzt
in der nacht gibt es in norddeutschland
einige wolken im süden bildet sich zum
teil auch nebel
es können wieder recht kalt werden
zumindest am alpenrand dort sinken die
temperaturen bis 3 grad dort droht also
bodenfrost milder bleibt die nacht
wieder rein oder auch auf den
ostfriesischen inseln morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen an der küste nur so
bei 15 bis 18 grad was kein wunder ist
denn das wasser von nord und ostsee ist
noch kalt hat so 11 bis 14 grad
wassertemperatur im binnenland wird es
deutlich wärmer mit 19 bis 25 grad und
am wärmsten nutzt morgen am oberrhein
denn südlich von mosel und main scheint
morgen die sonne strahlend im norden
sind die wolken dagegen etwas dichter
und sie können auch mal ein spritzer
regen bringen aber sehr viel wird das in
keinem fall bei einem wind aus
nordwestlichen richtungen
am donnerstag gibt es auch einige
regenschauer aber doch vor allen dingen
in nieder- und in oberbayern
danach geht es mit freundlichem wetter
weiter bei 15 bis 25 grad
schönen abend noch